what do you think about the way rappers
dress nowadays dusted us that one right
there bothers me
I ain't fond of seeing grown men with
with skinny jeans on and all of that
like just too tight
no disrespect the yato but you know you
could pop this a little bit you know hi
i'm gqueues Marc Anthony green by day
I'm a writer for the magazine and by
night when I'm not rewashing coming to
America and chasing girls that are
completely out of my league I'm hanging
out at our barbershop at Barclays Center
getting haircuts and talking with
interesting people hopefully they don't
cut my hair too bad all right
first time I had man so you know my do
said everything it's gonna be right so
oh what'd you get done today clean it up
yeah line it up make sure all that
crispy and then follow with a economy
that you go you got no straight line
when the last time you did a real good
good straight line every day every day
that's what I want to hit it cuz you
know I used to cut here I've never sold
ice cut in how we was shape up to home
the clip is the makeup shop is I will go
get some cooking oil and I would you
because you know cooking all you put
them on top of the blades but you be
shut up huh
you might you might smell like some good
wings yo man tell me about this album I
want to hear about the album this album
right here I got to say this is one of
my top works today you know on it you
could tell us any features and I really
don't like to give out all the goods
yeah give us what can we get one thing
for the barbershop yeah I'll give you
one I got the legendary snoop on an
album Oh
tell me about the the roots hang out the
five million dollar what is the Buddy
Guy selling it for an hour you know how
you go to an art gallery and you look at
a bunch of art pictures you know what
this project right here is basically
going to be
auction dinner and a museum whoever
comes with the with the highest valet is
the winner of this is classic venture
Java
coming around on me yeah yeah I think
rich isn't nervous so you gotta be
nervous he gotta be nervous
you know the boss Jeff is in your chair
I got the chef in my chair so everybody
respects you and I think people think
you're a very serious dude what are the
things that you do when you're just
trying to relax I love the clean line
yeah I know I'm a geek I'm a meat-free
yeah I like to sweep and vacuum and wash
dishes and all of that that's my high
right there yeah cooling out listening
to some great music who do your kids
listen to you listen to me my money I
got three beautiful babies two girls one
song what's the craziest thing about
being at that time man you got to give
kids time because they don't care about
anything else but being with you just
when you're not able to give them the
time that they deserve and you're just
watching them grow from a distance it
bothers you sometime but also you want
to let them know that you out there
making sure that they don't mean nothing
from nobody
let me ask you this non wu-tang top five
rappers of all time
nah yeah I would definitely say Rakim
uh-huh the great Fuji rap I will say LS
one more like one more Chuck D and the
top guy right now non wu-tang affiliate
I would say about to be allowed to be
jay-z man yeah you know that's that's
what I look at a lot of these artists
it's like oh right you don't now but can
you last twenty years right
how old is too old to be rapping like
when is just when is the cutoff when
it's like you know what I don't care how
good it is you're just too old
Wow right that's I say 5050
if you one of us if you you got to be a
match to them but you can't say because
talent is something that it comes within
so if you got it you got it
right that's all we gonna check check
these out in the mirror make sure they
didn't please clean is clean
hang on you think I'm tall on TV yeah
you know about sixteen twelve uh man
excellent job excellent job approval I
did a good job
weird up top that you should know
summertime summertime you had the easy
job
I know to lows low what are we going to
now right let's go get some food that
was a legendary Raekwon from the wu-tang
clan we heard his top five rappers and
he thinks jay-z's the best right now who
do you think is the best right now let
us know in the comment sections below
thanks for watching
[Music]